hello lisa
here we are season five season five
let's go we're out i can't believe it
it's hard for me and i can't imagine
what it's like for you
it's exciting yeah like it's like we get
to finish the story that we set out to
tell and not a lot of shows get to do
that so i'm just grateful that we got to
end it on our time and i bet you're
going out with the bank
i thought this panel was going to make
me feel like somebody but all it did was
remind me of where i'm at patty cake
patty cake
everything is out of my control you
never live i don't control where i go no
i don't want to take you and your
friends to palm springs it's tuesday
have you had something to eat no i got
to get right into it because i want to
know everything
where do we find issa at the beginning
of the season like what's her state of
mind i mean you find esa three months
after the the
season finale of last season of season
four
and she's really just focused on
trying to figure out how to move forward
if she can move forward and what she's
going to do with a lot of the momentum
that she's built with her her business
and in her personal life right so now
where do we find issa at the end of the
season is isa d more confident or she
still just as insecure i mean you gotta
watch the final look at you trying to
get spoilers
but i mean this is like this is a
journey of growth so if issa is in the
same place as she was in season one then
we failed
um so i do think you can count to see
and evolved we'd love to see that then
you know obviously
this show has meant so much to so many
people and it's been so groundbreaking
what memories are you gonna hold on to
the most like what has this show meant
to you but also what has it done for you
it's done everything for me are you
kidding me like this is
you know this is
where i was birthed in some ways you
know creatively and just with the family
that we have here and i'm gonna miss
the people the most you know behind the
scenes in front of the camera like every
person that was involved in making this
show uh did you steal anything from set
i am so dumb for not like i did not
steal i had a whole plan with yvonne she
was gonna steal stuff from my apartment
i was gonna steal stuff from hers but we
were shooting and they had ripped
everything down and taken it from us so
i was stolen from technically real quick
how has newlywed life been treating you
i mean you know i'm very happy yeah you
said it's your season wow um i don't
know what to say it's feeling like me
season right now
i feel so bad for anybody who doesn't
work with me um
mute me block me whatever you need to do
because it's it's a me season right now
it's my time
also beyonce ariana please don't release
anything during this time can you please
just let me have this and rihanna has
respected that rihanna do respect that
shout out to her i love her that's why
she's the best but this is your year
yeah i'ma claim it this is my season
there you go i love it thank you
congratulations
[Music]